Strike me down with all of your hatred
and your journey towards the dark side will be complete
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my top 20
Star Wars rise of Skywalker questions everyone had a lot of
questions about some of the plot turns
the mythology they changed a bunch of
things so we'll break it all down if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's going to be a bunch of Mandalorian stuff
coming up next week too so obviously
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen Star Wars rise of Skywalker because
we'll be talking about the end of the
movie really specific details so just once more spoiler warning here we go
starting with number 20 how did Palpatine survive the fall late
in the movie Emperor Palpatine says you
shall fall just as I once fell it's not
a metaphor it's a literal thing getting
thrown down a pit but the best explainer
is that he was able to use his Darkseid
Force abilities to preserve his body
upon impact in these Sith acolytes that
you see serving him here just happened
to also be on the Death Star and then
took him to the sith planet to try and
preserve his body before he completely
degraded but number 19 where did Snoke
come from if Emperor Palpatine says I
made Snoke what does that mean did he
engineer him did he just find him and
then turn him into his next acolyte and
if later in the movie he says that he is
all of the Sith and Rey has to kill him
and then the Sith will enter her and
she'll become Sith does that also mean
this Snoke was not ass if they get
really tricky with the rules in this
movie which is why there's a little bit
of confusion with some of the plot turns
the best explanation is that this Snoke
was a separate person that he found then
turned to his will and then proceeded to
clone a bunch of times because he was
using him for his plan
so the Snoke that we met during the
course of the new trilogy could have
been the second or third version of
Snoke it didn't have to be the first
necessarily the reason why Snoke looks
so broken is because he got into a fight
before Ben's Solo fell to the dark side
with Luke Skywalker and Luke Skywalker
did that to Snoke so that's why he kind
of walks with that weird limp that's why
his face is all messed up so number 18
follow-up question that's what's going
on with the tank of spare Snoke clones
they also kind of imply that those are
failed clones like oh this is their
attempts to clone smoke some of them are
more successful than others they just
throw the spares in this one tank here
and it just meant to look really freaky
is all about the Sith combining
technology with the force to manipulate
life is actually a pretty classic
Deepcut forsyth powers if you've ever
read Golden Age of the Sith or any the
Dark Horse Comics about the Sith
characters so number 17 follow-up
question if the rule of two had been a
big thing during the prequel series that
George Lucas said had been around for
centuries the way they explained it when
we got to Phantom Menace is that the
rule of two had been going on for a long
long time then where did the sith planet
come from and are all those sit in the
stands of the arena at the end of the
movie alive
were they just spirits and Palpatine is
conjuring them to freak ray out the name
of the planet is X ago so my
understanding is is that this is the
ancient planet of the Syst so I can
believe that at some point before the
rule of two this was a planet full of
Sith they're a bunch of other Sith
acolytes there but they don't feel like
they're full sit themselves my initial
interpretation of all the voices in the
chorus in the stands all those people
that were chanting while this was going
on we're just the spirits of the Sith
like he said all the Sith are within me
and he was just sort of conjuring them
to freak ray out but number 16 if
Palpatine was always planning on coming
back and had been making that fleet the
whole time why did he also bother having
Snoke go through the trouble of creating
another fleet in the first order why not
just start with a red assist trooper
fleet the best explanation I can think
of for this is that it was all about
baiting the galaxy was something that
was a little bit different like oh we
have something different from the Empire
we're not as bad as them we have a much
better way we have this new order we're
going to create it won't be like things
were before but surprised it's a lot
like things were before when they
actually do take over the galaxy
especially with the star killer base the
main reason why this feels kind of weird
is just because you have different
filmmakers for each of the different
films although technically JJ Abrams
came back at the last minute to do rise
of Skywalker but the whole idea with
those classic Star Destroyers and the
super lasers on them is that those are
meant to be miniaturized versions of the
Death Star lasers so that each one of
those many many Star Destroyers is
capable of destroying a planet by itself
so instead of having one big giant
planet killing away
been going around the galaxy you have
thousands of planet killing weapons but
number 15 this is a big one who were
raised parents and why did they leave
her on jakku her mother's actually jody
comer who you might recognize from the
BBC show killing eve i thought that was
actually a good choice of that actress
but the whole idea is is that Palpatine
had his son in that son married this
woman they had a child that child was
Rey and he was so afraid of his father
that he decided to leave and be no one
as they explained it was their way of
sort of massaging the big twist into
what was done during last Jedi even
though it doesn't feel like they
completely earned it like oh they
decided to be no:1 he explains to Rey at
the end of the movie that the plan was
always to bring her back and turn her to
the dark side and either have her take
over for him and become Empress
Palpatine or if she could not be turned
then he would just take over her body
with his fourth spirit big follow-up
question I saw this on all the Star Wars
videos that I posted who was Palpatine's
wife who did he get busy with to create
that son that then created Rey
because unless you're manipulating
midi-chlorians like he did with Anakin
Skywalker you can't get one without the
other I'll also explain that too another
follow-up after this
where did Anakin Skywalker come from and
is he also the son of Palpatine making
rey slightly part skywalker technically
the answer to that is no but i'll answer
that after i answered about Palpatine's
wife
so obviously Palpatine at some point
during his life had a humanoid female
woman that he was in love with or maybe
that he was just with didn't have to be
in love and had a child with her
everybody remember the Star Wars
underworld live-action TV series that
George Lucas had planned they wrote
about 50 episodes or so the scripts are
all done but they canceled it before
they started shooting it because he sold
Lucasfilm to Disney before they started
ramping up on production for that during
that series there was going to be a
woman that was a member of the criminal
underworld a fairly powerful crime boss
that Palpatine had been in love with at
some point and she had broken his heart
so it's implied that they had had a
relationship at some point it's possible
that his son came from that woman
there's also a lot of people during the
prequels that see this woman slime or
the bald woman next to him she's a dark
side force at it who always served him
and stayed nearby him it's also possible
that that's Ray's grandmother numbers
13 question why does kylo Ren been
so low see Han Solo if Han Solo isn't
capable of becoming a force ghost they
kind of explained this through the
course of the movie as he's talking
through like what are you doing here oh
I'm just a figment of your imagination
I'm a memory of yours because you notice
that Han Solo isn't glowing blue like a
force ghost so really what's going on in
this moment is is that kylo Ren is
talking to himself I realized what I
have to do but I don't know if I can do
it and he sort of remembering Han Solo
as he was during the moment where he
killed him it's meant to be a callback
to them on the walkway during Force
awakens on the Starkiller base number 12
when did Leia complete her Jedi training
and become a master as ray calls her
during the movie master there's this
idea that sometime after Return of the
Jedi Leia started to complete her Jedi
training with Luke Skywalker she even
made a lightsaber which shows up during
the movie but then sends through the
force that her son had been tempted by
the dark side of the force and it scared
her so much that she just put it aside
that's why her lightsaber had been with
Luke Skywalker on that island the whole
time it's implied though that in the 25
years between when that happened and the
new trilogy that she completed her
training enough so that she could help
train rays so I dunno if she was able to
become a full Jedi Master but also it's
implied that because she became a force
ghost at some point one of the force
ghosts of the past either obi-wan or
Yoda or someone else taught her how to
do it to both Ben's Solo and Leia turn
into force ghost during the movie but
technically you actually have to learn
how to do that you don't just do that
because you're a Jedi number 11 why were
the little triangle sis devices called
Sith wayfinders instead of just calling
them Sith holocrons like they were
designed to look all the longtime Star
Wars fans ply saw this pop up for the
first time before they started talking
about it and thought Oh sis holocrons
that's great okay Jedi holocrons are
pretty cool of course they're Sith
holocrons it makes sense that they would
include that in the film big deep cut
Easter egg I think the reason why they
call them Sith wayfinders instead is
really just for the general audience
that's not familiar with expanded Star
Wars Canon and they just wanted to make
it as simple to understand as possible
oh this thing is going to help me get to
that place and that's the only reason
they did that they only exist in the
movie to be MacGuffins to get them from
point A to point
be number 10 question follow-up if
one of them had belonged to Darth Vader
did he also travel to the sith planet
had he been here before have you ever
heard the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the
wise so if Anakin Skywalker wanted to
learn all about cheating death
the secrets would probably be on this
planet so we think it's safe to assume
that he spent some time here number 9
big question that I softer the movie is
Finn actually force sensitive because
it's several points in the film he says
I have a feeling and even later in the
movie he starts to sense things that are
happening to Rey from very very far away
the fact that they do it so many times
makes me feel like yes he is definitely
force sensitive she even passes him the
lightsaber which i think is a callback
to force awakens where finn used the
lightsaber a couple of different times
number eight also a big question why
does Ray's new lightsaber look like that
with a very different looking black hilt
in the yellow Kyber crystal
metaphorically I think it's just the
idea that she's accepted who she comes
from
she's a Palpatine she comes from evil
that's what the black is meant to
represent I wouldn't be surprised this
is just speculation but I would not be
surprised if some of the metal of that
lightsaber was taken from the metal of
the wreckage of the second Death Star
it's all part of the themes of the whole
new trilogy even if it wasn't clear it
doesn't matter where you come from it's
all about who you choose to be you could
choose to be a good person even if you
come from evil so I think metaphorically
making a lightsaber that looks like that
it just meant to acknowledge where she
comes from
as for the yellow Kyber crystal I think
that's a bit of a meta reference to not
only the character choosing a new path
not something that's come before so it's
not green like Luke Skywalker's it's not
blue like Anakin Skywalker's is
obviously not red because she's not a
darkside Sith force user it just meant
to show you oh this is going to be going
in a new direction now and you just kind
of left to wonder what that's going to
look like number seven question what
does it mean that Rey and kylo Ren are a
force dyad so what they say is that
there are two halves of one force being
in two different bodies but how were
they born that way did it have something
to do with some crazy midi-chlorians
explainer was Palpatine responsible for
doing this it's been explained that
Snoke didn't know about the force dyad
he wasn't aware of what was going on
during last Jedi when they were both
together so if he didn't know I think
it's safe to assume that Palpatine
didn't always
know that they were a force dyad maybe
only discovered that pretty late in the
game but they get into a lot of this
really crazy expanded force Lord during
Star Wars the Clone Wars
maybe they'll address that when the
Clone Wars comes back in February that's
actually when all those Clone Wars
episodes were going to air but the idea at
the end of the movie with them sharing
each other's lifeforce like she heals
him earlier in the movie with a little
bit of her life force and then at the
end of the movie he heals her with the
last of his life force like it's not
enough for him to be able to continue to
live so that's why he dies but because
they're one-half of one force being
metaphorically what they're trying to
say is is that now it's two halves of
one person that been so low half of that
force dyad now lives within ray and
she's one complete person so even though
his physical body is dead he lives on
and her that's why he sort of
disappeared and turned into a force
ghost but number six also big cannon
question what does it mean when
Palpatine says he contains all the souls
of the Sith who came before the whole
idea before this movie is that the rules
were that Sith could not become force
ghosts only Jedi there's a line of
dialogue from Yoda somewhere before this
where he says something about the Sith
not being able to use this is a path to
immortality the way this is typically
preserved their lives are either through
technology technology like the emperor
has here or literally just transplanting
their force essence into someone else
and taking over their body they could
bind their souls to objects but you
never really saw all these souls living
within one person so this is a brand new
thing that they either introduced for
this movie or just something that they
made up at the last minute so don't tie
yourselves in a knot trying to figure
this out too much but number 5 what's
the deal with the Knights of Ren in this
movie they never fully explained them
but they're basically Darkseid acolytes
not full Sith themselves because they
don't use lightsabers they just use
those weapons clearly they really serve
Palpatine because they turn on Ben solo
when he becomes Ben solo again coming
back to the sith planet number four this
is also a big question what was Finn
going to tell to Rey they had several
scenes in the movie and even Poe Dameron was like you going to tell her when Poe's
not around is that what's going on here
if it wasn't clear from that very
leading Poe Dameron line there he was
going to try and tell her that he loved
her until he met the female version of
Finn he literally meets another girl who
was a stormtrooper and has the exact
same backstory that he does
that's why I'm calling her female fin
but number three big question why did
Rey choose the Skywalker name at the end
of the movie and is she really related
to Anakin Skywalker because technically
they both come from Palpatine the main
reason why she takes the Skywalker name
is to honor them and because they felt
like the family that she never had like
Luke Skywalker was the father she never
had Leia was the mother she never had
yes technically she is kind of related
to Anakin Skywalker because they were
both created by Palpatine but not by
blood not by genetic material
Palpatine used his sift hours in the
midi-chlorians to create a fetus out of
nothingness implant that into Shmi
Skywalker and that's where Anakin
Skywalker came from he has no biological
father
Rey was created the old-fashioned way
she is the direct biological
granddaughter of Palpatine so
technically she's not related to the
Skywalker's but you could claim a loose
connection between their two lines
number two follow-up question what is
Rey going to do next now after she
buries these two lightsabers on Tatooine
in the moisture farm if you've been
listening to the rise of Skywalker
soundtrack the really interesting detail
is that the track that plays over this
scene is called a new home does that
imply that Rey is now going to live on
Tatooine and continue her Jedi training
here she has all the Jedi texts so I
think it's implied that she's going to
do the same thing that Luke Skywalker
did after Return the Jedi try to rebuild
the Jedi Order and eventually create a
new temple of her own so the number one
question where is baby Yoda in all
this because if he's about 50 right now
in the Mandalorian and what's happening
in the movies is about 25 years after
that he'd be way more powerful but he'd
still be a relative young Ling by the
standards of his race eventually they
would have to cross paths and they would
have to start training together but then
the idea is that the legacy of the Jedi
because baby Yoda is so long-lived he
lived for potential 900 years like Yoda
he would become the future of the Jedi
and lived to see all those future
generations if you have any big
questions about the movie that I didn't
answer in this video just write them
below in the comments but hopefully that
answers most of the big ones there's an
easter egg video that I'll try to do
tomorrow I also have some Witcher
Netflix videos because that series just
started and there'll be some Mandalorian
stuff coming up real soon
so everyone click here for my brand new
Mandalorian video and click here for my
full rise of Skywalker review thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
I'll see you guys tonight!